what's up everyone its Warren we have
the final trailer for Star Wars the rise
of Skywalker I know I'm a little late
here but I'm currently in Paris so the
time zone is a little bit different so
I'm in my hotel right now but I'm going
to watch it for the first time let's go
[Music]
feeling
the horse brought together
we're not alone
good people will fight if we lead them
[Music]
people keep telling me they know me
[Music]
and I wonders
[Music]
have I waited
you're coming together
is your undoing
what are we doing there 3 bill taking
one last look sir but my friends
[Music]
confronting fear the destiny of it
[Music]
your destiny
[Music]
the force will be with you always
[Music]
oh man the music gets you every time the
that was Palpatine and Dan there's
there's no way that wasn't Palpatine at
the end wow that's crazy that one line I
don't remember exactly what it was
rayou array no no one knows me or
something like that and then kylo I know
you that sounds like Darkseid ray I know
there's a lot of debate going around
right now whether that scene from the
other footage is a force vision or if
it's actually dark side ray that kind of
sounds like it's a dark side ray who
knows what's gonna happen but uh wow I
think they've done a really good job at
getting people excited again this
trailer was awesome I thought it was
really awesome the footage and it was
really really great I think they did an
amazing job I think it's gonna be a
really good movie I hope everybody else
enjoys that I'll do a breakdown later on
but this was really good I really
enjoyed it let me know what everybody
thinks about this and the comments down
below and as always thanks for watching
wolf loaf